[Musique]
allons-nous commencer d'
accord détendez-vous comme si vous dormiez vous
dormez vous rêvez d'un
[ __ ] à l'air d'un démon de huit pieds de haut
oh oui un rêve j'aime que les
rêves soient des endroits où vous pouvez vous
amuser, tout est dans votre esprit alors  pourquoi ne pas en
profiter Chut écoute vas-y et regarde
[Musique]
maintenant récupéré dans ton rêve
prends soin d'une situation comme celle-ci nous
venons de mettre le nom de Kenny et voyons ce qui
se passe
Je sais que tu veux continuer à l'aider je
ne '  Je ne sais pas alors c'est une bonne chose que tu
ailles bien au
lit maintenant tant que nous jouons faisons-le
bien il n'y a pas besoin de l'arrêter
oh je suis désolé quoi d'autre y a-t-il à quel point les
cochons ne sont pas mauvais du tout
Musique]
toutes les personnes qui rendent la vie misérable
rendent la vie dangereuse et
si nous pouvions changer les choses
l'humain dont le nom est écrit
et mourra
devrions-nous commencer votre mort dieu oui que
puis-je faire exactement avec cette mort
Non écrivez votre nom et voyez quoi
ça ne va pas résoudre quelques crimes ça
va résoudre tous les crimes  pensez-vous que
je suis fou je pense que vous n'êtes pas
assez gelé nous pourrions changer le monde le
tueur s'est attribué le mérite de plus de 400
morts bien que nous ne sachions pas comment il
tue ses victimes nous savons qu'il n'est
pas d'une force limitée il est  une personne
comme toi ou moi tu es celui qui a volé
vers le soleil je suis juste ici pour m'assurer que
tu as roté
nous ne sommes plus les gentils tu
sais ce que tu fais
[Applaudissements]
je te promets que tu vas  Je ne vois pas
ce qu'ils veulent, c'est parti alors donnons-le-
leur
[Musique]